muchas caras de alegría se vieron en el
concierto de nueva york- los asistentes
presentaron su carné de vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 lo que les dio más seguridad
para estar en medio de la multitud a las
afueras las filas rodearon el central
park' la emoción se sentía en el
ambiente
me siento muy bien siento que la ciudad
se está abriendo tengo la vacuna y ahora
puedo estar en medio de la gente hay una
energía increíble y todo va a estar muy
bien
por la inclemencia del tiempo el
concierto no alcanzó a durar ni dos
horas y fue cancelado abruptamente en
medio de una actuación una tormenta
vinculada al huracán henri cubrió a
nueva york- que fue puesta en estado de
emergencia sin embargo el evento se
retomó un par de horas después el
alcalde de la ciudad había pedido a la
gente no salir de sus casas
queremos que haga sus planes de manera
correcta para minimizar la actividad del
domingo en la mayor medida posible
manténgase alejado de las carreteras y
que desee adentro habrá fuertes vientos
mucha lluvia y podríamos ver algunos
árboles cayendo necesitamos que la gente
esté segura así que lo digo ahora para
que pueda modificar sus planes
los neoyorquinos se enfrentan de nuevo
un fenómeno que recuerda al huracán
sandy en 2012 y que en su camino incluyó
las costas de nueva jersey y 9 y está en
la lista de los más mortíferos en la
historia de eeuu provocó 147 muertes y
daños por 65 mil millones de dólares